are you guys allow me to welcome you to
a Campeche yeah it's good to be here
does it feel like camp a little bit yeah
I'm not sure how I feel about the the
chairs are too small it's perfect for me
really we got our juices yeah but you
know what actually is actually hold on
mmm we also got um Big Boy drinks if you
wanna know yeah I mean I will have a
vodka please Bert this is a big day this
is what you think I like it
tequila right how many big plans for you
this is our third yes yeah so how
different is it now than your first one
it's just bigger it's big yeah it's just
bigger than every time it shocks me I'm
just like how did more people get in
here so do you guys have any tips
surviving this crazy you can cuz you
interact with a lot of fans just a
standard stuff we're just like stay
hydrated make sure you eat because I I
completely forget to do that I have to
have people remind me yes hmm so I think
it's that and also if you do see someone
that you like and I discuss for us as
well like don't go crazy
they are just humans yes so I think that
you just need to remember that they
aren't just a 2d image on a screen they
are a really real person yeah tell me
more about this series mm-hmm and so
it's called Jack Neil or trades and the
premise is Jack and Nina are two guys
who become temps and in every episode
they have a different job but we use the
job sort of as a context to allow all
the weird stuff to happen because like
all their videos of like sketches like
music Jack walks into your room Dean
ziba turned into something on it's done
something bizarre and we were like we
didn't want to lose that obvious because
that's what we feel like we've kind of
practice and honed in and it obviously
it'd be silly if we try to go too far
away from North we already know what are
you guys looking forward to in the next
year then what else is coming out we're
really hoping that we get to do another
series yeah that's well that we've
already started thinking about ideas
yeah there's like we've got all sorts of
stuff like I just want to keep making
stuff and then I want to be in Star Wars
within the next 10 years make a really
good like you want yeah I was about to
say like realistically I think like a
mocap creature yeah you know you know
from the moment back next summer we'll
have a bar the next time like I
mentioned and enjoy the rest of your
VidCon yeah you see thank you very much